et si justement vous préférez les fêtes
de fin d'année locale et ben bonne
nouvelle puisque le Loir est cher à son
propre foie gras nous vous emmenons à
présent à la découverte de ce foie gras
100 % local il est produit à la ferme de
la faubonnière à Cheverny en circuit
très court donc vous l'aurez compris un
établissement que vous retrouverez ce
weekend sur les stands de ferme expo
alors pour ceux qui souhaitent donner
des couleurs locales à leur fête de fin
d'année voici un reportage chis Roméo
marm saucisse magré et même chilicon
canard à la ferme de la faubonnière dans
le sud du loircher l'animal se décline à
toutes les sauces à l'approche de la
ferme expo des dizaines de bêtes sont
détaillé chaque semaine pour être
cuisiné donc le foie gras pour faire du
mi cuit ou en foie gras frais les
manchons de canard qui peuvent aller en
rillette ou en confit les cuisses de
canard pareil fraîche ou en confit et
attention pas de gâchis on utilise aussi
le gras la carcasse et le cœur de
l'animal mais tout en préparant
l'événement il faut continuer de livrer
des volailles aux clients car la ferme
de la fauonière de fait pas que du
canard mais aussi du poulet chez épesé
j'ai mis une une étiquette dessus avec
la DLC le Lot et le poids cette année
pour financer un stand à la ferme expo
l'exploitation a bénéficié du label C du
centre une marque qui vise à mettre en
avant les produits de la région
centreval de Loire fait un retour à
ferme expo on était absent depuis
2019 donc on sera présent sur le village
gastronomique et on proposera des
produits à à emporter et également de la
rest
à consommer sur place rendez-vous donc
du 17 au 19 novembre au marché des
producteurs à la ferme Expo pour
déguster les produits emblématique du
Loir etcher le département mit à
l'honneur cette
année